هذا هو المكان الذي دُفن فيه ميكولا كوليشينكو حياً ، حيث تم إجبار الجنود الروس على ارتداء
معصوب العينين الذي يقول إنه وشقيقيه
الذين لا يزالون متناثرين بالقرب من قبرهم الضحل
يظهر لنا أين دخلت الرصاصة في خده
قُتل إخوته جافين وديميترو
لكنه تمكن من الفرار.
قبرهم كان علي أن أعيش لأروي هذه القصة ليس
للأوكرانيين ولكن للعالم
يقول مكتب المدعي العام الإقليمي أن
تحقيقًا في جرائم الحرب قد تم فتح
هذا منزل ميشيلا حيث كان يعيش
مع شقيقيه مع أختهم
في 18 مارس.  جاء الجنود
الروس إلى القرية بحثًا عن رجال
يعتقدون أنهم مسؤولون عن
هجوم على إحدى قوافلهم ،
وذلك عندما بدأ كابوس العائلة
دخل ثلاثة جنود المنزل بحثًا
عن أي شيء قد يربط
الإخوة بالهجوم على القافلة.
لم يجدوا شيئًا سوى ما وجدوه كان
شيئًا يربط العائلة
بالجيش على شكل أجدادهم
ميدالية عسكرية
وجدوا أيضًا حقيبة جافين العسكرية
لأنه كان يستعد للذهاب والقتال لمدة أربعة أيام بصفته جندي احتياطي في الجيش الأوكراني
، لم
تسمع
شقيقتهم إيرينا شيئًا من إخوتها حتى عاد ميكولا من الموت ،
وعدت إلى المنزل وكان هناك
ميكولا نظرت  في عينيه وسأل عن
مكان الآخرين
، فقال إنه
لا يوجد آخرون
[موسيقى]
قال نيكولاس إنه بعد نقلهم من
منزلهم ، تم
تعصيب أعين الإخوة الثلاثة واستجوابهم في قبو
لمدة أربعة أيام
، ثم تعرضوا للضرب ونقلهم إلى
موقع
بعد شهرين من إعدامهم ، ما زال يكافح للتحدث
عما أفكر به عن الروس ،
أنا أكرههم من كل روحي ،
إنهم حيوانات يجب أن يحرقوها في
الجحيم
، كان ذلك فقط بعد انسحاب روسيا
بعد شهر من إعدامهم.
الدفن اللائق
شاهد القبر والسلام
الذي حرم ميخائيل